وشددت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه على انها
ستواصل مراقبه مستويات عنف المستوطنين
المتطرفين وذلك بعد ان فرضت واشنطن عقوبات
على اربعه مستوطنين قالت انهم متورطون في
العنف بالضفه
الغربيه اولا العقوبات تبعث برساله انه
يتعين على حكومه اسرائيل القيام بالمزيد
ثانيا سنتخذ اجراءات ضد اولئك الذين
ينخرطون في اعمال عنف المستوطنين
المتطرفين الذين تمت محاكمتهم من قبل
الحكومه واولئك الذين لم تتم ملاحقتهم جزء
من رسالتنا ليس موجها الى الحكومه
الاسرائيليه فحسب بل ايضا الى الاشخاص
الذين قد يفكرون في الانخراط في اعمال عنف
لاعلامه بان الولايات المتحده تراقب
وستتخذ الاجراءات اللازمه الامر التنفيذي
الذي صدر اليوم يمنح وزارتي الخارجيه
والخزانه سلطات فرض عقوبات جديده ولن
نتردد في استخدامها اذا كان من المناسب
القيام بذلك